- [Narrator] It was a
dark time for “Star Wars”
when CG characters started popping
into every corner of the series.
(Jabba the Hutt shrieking)
But before Jar Jar stumbled
into our collective consciousness ...
(blasters firing)
- Oh no!
- [Narrator] “Star Wars”
was all about puppets.
Which brings us to this guy.
- I'm Dave Barclay.
I'm a puppeteer and puppet builder
and animatronic effects supervisor.
- [Narrator] You might
recognize Dave better
under 200 pounds of fiberglass and latex,
because he was one of the
puppeteers inside Jabba the Hutt.
(Jabba grumbling)
But to play the most notorious
gangster on Tataouine,
you gotta start somewhere.
And Dave ...
Well, he got his big break
with a little green man.
(dramatic orchestral music)
- That is why you fail.
- [Narrator] Yoda was famously
puppeteered by Frank Oz,
the legend behind Cookie
Monster and Grover.
- Show you near and far.
- Yoda not far. (chuckling)
- [Narrator] But Yoda
was a complicated puppet,
and it took four to five people
working different body
parts to bring him to life.
Dave's job was controlling
Yoda's eyes and ears.
- There was a sequence when Yoda
is prodding Mark with a stick, saying,
- [Dave And Yoda] "Where
he was, what he was doing."
- And I'm doing a little squint
and subtle control on the eyes.
Yup, right there, that's
me doing the eyes there.
Towards the end of the
filming on Empire Strikes Back
Frank Oz was performing Yoda,
and it became clear he had
to move on to another film
and he wasn't gonna be available,
so they needed someone
to take over for Yoda,
and Frank nominated me.
I was 19 years old.
So, suddenly there I am with Yoda.
- [Narrator] Even at 19 years old,
Dave's Yoda scenes blended
perfectly with Frank Oz.
(Yoda yelling)
That was Dave!
Did you guys see that?
Let's take one more look.
(Yoda yelling)
Dave did such a good
job, they called him back
and asked him to run a new
puppet called Jabba the Hutt.
- Jabba the Hutt was
probably the most complicated
and sophisticated animatronic puppet
that anyone had ever tried to build,
and it took six to
seven people to operate.
Inside Jabba, it was very
claustrophobic, very close.
One person doing the left hand,
the head movement and the tongue.
Another puppeteer doing
the mechanical tail.
Another puppeteer doing the
breathing on the air bladders.
I did Jabba's right
hand, and I did his jaw,
and then I provided the voice on stage.
My voice doesn't make it to screen,
but if you turned up on set,
you'll hear this sort of voice.
- Where's my torque drive? (grumbling)
- As a child, there
weren't really any movies
that had puppeteers in them.
There was a little bit here and there,
but there were no solid
characters like Yoda.
And being part of the Yoda team,
which really was the first
performance animatronic in movies
was the start of this huge growth
that lasted about 20 years.
And as a puppeteer and as a puppet maker
and someone who loves the movies,
I was in the exactly the
right place at the right time
and have had a wonderful
career doing what I adore,
so I feel very lucky and privileged.